rose mcgowan claims she was sexually  assaulted by a well-known Hollywood  executive the outspoken actress took to  social media on Friday revealing she was  allegedly raped Rose shared in a series  of tweets using the hashtag why women  don't report quote a female criminal  attorney said because I've done a sex  scene in a film I would never win  against the studio head McGowan also  claims it was an open secret in  Hollywood media and she was later shamed  in the entertainment industry the charm  star further stated my ex sold our movie  to my rapist for distribution McGowan's  comments come as the National Dialogue  turns to ongoing claims that  presidential candidate Donald Trump made  sexual advances and lewd comments about  women in closing on her past rape  allegations the actress tweeted it is  time for some goddamn honesty in this  world it's like so over already